Larry thanks for joining us when's the
last time you called a horse race where
he had visibility that poor I've
actually had a few that are worse than
that over the years where you really
couldn't see anything but it's been a
while and certainly it wasn't a Triple
Crown race so it's a little bit
different with when that much is on the
line what's the strategy when you're not
able to make out the horses as clearly
as you'd like well normally then I call
every race with my binoculars and that
was pretty much not going to happen with
this race so luckily I had two monitors
in front of me and I had discussed about
10 minutes before the race for the
director of our show Pierre Moussa that
showed me all the angles that he planned
on showing in all the different shots in
the different places and we sort of
strategize the best way to do it went
from there
but is there modern technology are there
chips in the saddles of these horses
like can is there computer tracking as
you're doing play-by-play there is that
does exist however I wasn't able to use
that information I did not know if I
guess somewhere they may have had that
maybe on the on the feed but Pimlico the
track itself was showing but I don't
think we use that for the NBC coverage
and and I didn't have any access to it
so I was just going by what I could see
on the monitors when do you know you've
seen a great horse I mean it it's that's
a that's a tough question I think a lot
of it has to do with with who they beat
and how they beat them and I I would say
that justify is going to rank up there
as one of the best ones I mean it's to
be determined still whether he can pull
it off in the Belmont Stakes I certainly
think he can but I mean we've seen some
great horses over the years and
obviously recent memory American Pharoah
would be the latest of those how does
somebody get into the business of being
a track announcer I started back when I
was a kid it's all I've ever done I
called my first race when I was 18 years
old my father put in the sound system at
one of the tracks in Maryland where I
grew up and just started calling races
over and all
were into a into a tape recorder with a
pair of binoculars until they heard me
one day and said hey I think we're good
enough and I started calling races you
know at age 18 over the Maryland track
sort of went from there
practice practice practice that's the
best way to get better at it but you're
looking at numbers you're looking at
names so how how do you you know I guess
trying to figure that out we had this in
sports where we see numbers and we know
names attached to it but with horses you
know you're seeing a different race you
know every what 15 20 minutes so it's a
little bit different there so how do you
do that where you're doing the word
association its jockeys silks that I go
by because that's the best way to
discern the horses from each other those
are the colors of each individual
courses owner and that's the way to be
able to tell them apart what I do is
when the horses come on the track I just
repeat their names over and over until I
feel like I know who they are without
having to look at my program obviously a
race like the Derby or the Preakness you
do that well in advance with the
preparation by banking you know cue
cards so you know who they are look at
look at one side with the silks and say
hey that's justified that's good magic
until you just have them just embedded
in your memory and then you know with a
normal racing day as soon as that race
crosses the wire they just leave your
head and you have to dump all that
information out and in a half an hour
call in other words you ever made a
glaring mistake I have once or twice
yeah we had a way to race at Aqueduct a
couple years back called the Wood
Memorial which is a pretty big prep race
for the Kentucky Derby and there was a
horse down on the inside it was sort of
foggy that day not quite as bad as the
Preakness but I thought it was another
horse all the way up until the wire and
as soon as they hit the Y I real
realized I was not calling the right
horse for the entire stretch run it was
it was pretty embarrassing and luckily
it wasn't the last race I called that
day so I could sort of recover in a half
an hour well you also had August of 2010
at Monmouth Park which is one of your
better moments I think nationally or at
least the opportunity for people to
realize what you do and you're you don't
know how these horses are going
twine when you look at the program but
it seemed intertwined magically that day
so we'll take you back to that call
here's a Larry coldness at Monmouth Park
my wife knows everything broke well lady
boo tada is up and on the pace rojos
tune is out third the wife doesn't know
forth to the outside and Elena's hope is
fifth as they move for the first turn on
the far outside Little Miss macho is
going up after that tardy start all the
way up to battle with the leaders on the
lucky side is next a ground saving trip
for Morningside Heights late for class
in miss Tallahassee or in the back of
the field as Lady mutata
leads the way to the back stretch on the
far outside the wife doesn't know is
moving up and is now fourth and right
alongside if my wife knows everything my
wife knows everything and the wife
doesn't know are moving together on the
fire turn and they're coming after Lady
Mutara coming to the quarter pole lady
Mutara in front here come my wife knows
everything and the wife doesn't know on
the far outside
Little Miss macho is fourth are into the
stretch
lady Mutara my wife knows everything
Center the track the wife doesn't know
into the final furlong my wife knows
everything the wife doesn't know they're
one two of course they are my wife knows
everything in prime to the outside the
wife doesn't know my wife knows
everything the wife doesn't know my wife
knows everything more than the wife
doesn't know
oh you can't script it any better than
that Larry well that's what they threw
at me you know those those horses says
you know absolutely nothing in common it
was a complete coincidence that they
showed up in the same race as you could
see as the race was developing that this
could this could happen they were
starting to move together I'm like okay
here we go and just wanted to get
through it you know the names right and
finish it out and I got a couple of text
messages from friends afterwards and all
of a sudden I guess it became a little
bit bigger deal and I didn't get youtube
hits like crazy it was fun did you have
ever anything close to that where you're
putting two horses together or three
horses together with the names that you
would never
do that or never thought you'd do that
no I don't think so I think that was a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to have
like that come along so I don't
anticipate it happening again although I
tell people I I prefer to be more known
for calling American Pharoah's Triple
Crown but that but a lot of people seem
to enjoy it so I guess I should too do
people ask you to do voice messages or
their phone message their outgoing
message not as much as you think that
every once in a while I did get a guy
recently that was having an 80th
birthday party for his father and wanted
me to stage a fake horse race for them
using all their names and I said sure
why not I did it for him so it's a fun
thing to do and every once in a while
you get that that's cool that's cool I
asked doc Emmerich if he gets people who
want to have his voice on their of their
phone he said yes and so he does I can
understand Larry thank you a great job
over the weekend and we appreciate you
sense of humor thanks for joining us no
problem man anytime that's Larry Coleman
see NBC track announcer for the
Preakness for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]